the answer is very very short
we looked at the contracts for the
gas supply and the others supply
it says that
sometimes payments are made in euros, but usually
in euros and i made it clear in the conversation with
the russian president
that this is also the case  will remain and what
his ideas are that that
can happen
that's what we're going to
look at now but in any case it
applies to the companies that they
can and will want to pay in euros for
germany you can say we'll
probably
give it a go we work  the companies
and our turn over the course of this year will
manage to eliminate our dependence on oil and
coal imports
and we will
need a little longer with regard to gas, but
for everything you also need
transport capacities either in the form
of trains and trucks that
can transport something in  form of
ships and ports that are suitable for
this or in the form  von
packt 1
[music]
i was able to get my characters of
the opera
and captains of
the european
commission
[music]
euro through the euro is ok
contracts are contracts and this is not
new news and this is a fixed
position of all european
members